[Music]
ryan is with us in denver hey ryan
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you dave it's an honor to talk to
you and great to see you on the show
george
thank you how can we help today
so here's my situation so i have a
current
job offer to make about 30 000 above
what i currently make and
the ability to work 100 remote
the problem is i like the firm i'm at
currently and i just got a promotion
with a nice pay raise and bonus
so i'm torn between being loyal to
my current employer and the co-workers
that i really like or
taking the pay bump in the opportunity
that seems like the better deal
for the moment
well if you took work remote out of it
it might change my answer
and um because i am
seeing several pieces of valid research
come out
that is very clearly saying man was not
meant to be alone
and the productivity and the quality of
work coming out of
remote working companies is going to be
and is uh less than
companies that actually work where
people actually work together
being in the same room with someone has
a multitude of advantages from
communication
to quality of relationships to trust to
uh and all of that affects productivity
and affects
quality of life on the job so um
remote workers are you know the research
is coming out they're just
straight up lonely um but it sounds
really appealing for someone who's not
necessarily an extrovert
and it sounds really appealing for
certain job types for you to sit at home
and pack on a computer and get it done
uh but at the end of the day it's not
turning out the way everybody thought it
was going to so
i i think that's a temporary move if you
take it i don't think it's a career
uh you know uh destination for you it's
i'm gonna go take this because it's 30
grand but i'm pretty sure in 24 months
i'll be doing something else
yeah and ryan you said you you really
like your coworkers you're going to miss
that when you're on zoom calls all day
it's going to feel like you don't have
any
so what's your current income right now
what what kind of jump are we talking
like from 69 000 up to 90
yeah what do you do i'm an auditor for a
public accounting firm
okay um well it would be unbelievably
tacky
for you to walk in and go you guys just
gave me a raise and i want another one
it's not enough
so i i mean i'm i'm interested
how old are you i'm 24.
wow okay what would be your best theory
as to why you're worth a hundred
thousand to one company and seventy
thousand to another
i mean uh the job offers kind of for
a little more specific type work um
okay sorry so um i would say
the reason is for uh just just the
qualifications that you would have to
have
for this for this new type type of job
but
you know what's that don't you have
those qualifications
yes okay so why are you only worth
70 for one company and you're worth 100
for the other with the same exact
qualifications
um i just just the line of work i mean
it's kind it's different
different type of work so with auditing
there's a lot of
there's a lot of opportunity a lot of
people coming into the market you know
um and and it took takes a little
while at bigger firms to kind of work up
um whereas you're very replaceable
in audit um unlike uh this type of
industry that i'd be moving into
it's kind of more specific and does your
firm
offer does your firm offer that service
that's specific that this other firm
offers
so they do but not not at the location
not in denver
okay where's this new job at if you is
it local or is it remote
oh it's all remote so you wouldn't have
to go anywhere yeah
yeah here's the thing i'm worried you
take this thing and you realize oh my
gosh i hate these people and it's toxic
and it's super stressful and i'm working
60 hours a week
and it's not what i thought it was and
it's not worth 50 grand let alone 30.
yeah i i you do what you want to do i
don't think there's a wrong answer
if you take it um i'm going to introduce
the idea that it's more temporary than
maybe you had thought
because i think you're going to run into
problems 24 36 months out
because i think we're going to start to
see this is my theory we do
ramsey doesn't have remote work we don't
have any
okay because we really have seen a major
difference when we're in the same
building together as a matter of fact we
spend an
inordinate amount of money being in the
same building together building the dead
gum building
you know and so we believe in it that
much we believe in the net result to the
customer
uh the net result of the quality of work
the uh environment the retention of
talent
the culture and so forth so all of that
to say
you're asking a guy who has a skewed
opinion on this
um and so my theory is if you take that
other deal it's going to be a temporary
deal and that's okay to do it 24.
if you want to make 30 grand more a year
that's not a bad thing and you got
a bunch of freedom from work remote
that's fine but i don't think you'll be
there when you're 30.
still doing that uh just based on
talking to you and i think these trends
are going to
blow up a lot of people are already
zoomed out i'll just tell you
and so uh but but now the other thing
you could do
if you don't take it is i would go back
into the current firm and say
i've got this offer on the table i'm not
going to take it
but i think it's fair to let you guys
know this is on the table and i am
staying here
because of the relationships and what i
and and because i value this firm and
uh you guys just gave me a raise i'm 24.
now
but what i do want you to know is that
you're going to have to show me a path
forward
and because the next time this comes up
i got to think about it again
and so just you don't have to do it
today but over the next coming months
you need to give me a path forward where
i
can earn more money for this firm so you
can pay me more money
i want to know how i can add value yeah
so that i can make more
and if you do that with humility and
you've got the work ethic and you've got
the chops and you ask for hey i just
want a growth plan i'm willing to work
and do what it takes to get to that
salary just let me know what it takes
and let's have that conversation and the
way i do this too is
is i reverse the shoes and say okay put
your employer's shoes on
i got a 24 year old guy walks into my
office and goes
i just turned down a 30 000 race
not uh hey look what i got okay
uh cause i'm gonna tell you take it yeah
if you come in waving that under my nose
go for it as an employer i'd say
you feeling hoppy jump it's your last
day you know that's good
you know your spirit leaves you i'll
take your body with it so let's do that
you know i'm going to be mean about it
but i'm just
as so if you switch see seats though and
you say okay if you're the employer
and the young man walks in and says i
just turned this down
because i'm thankful for this place
being loyal
i'm also telling you what's going on and
really all i ask is in the next few
months that you've shown me how i can
add value so that i'm worth thirty
thousand dollars more
in various in the very near future yeah
uh not asking you to match this
uh but but i am asking you show me a way
where i can be valuable
now an employer like me that guy that
gal
i love him that's perfect yeah because
that's somebody that's in it to win it
for the long term
with the team they're gonna stick around
it's gonna be worth investing in them
it's gonna be worth giving them maybe an
immediate raise even
but you don't ask for it no not today do
with humility
that's it that's the whole thing